Allen is with us Allen is in New Orleans
hi Ellen welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
i mr. Andy thanks for a few minutes your
time sure how can I help so I have some
debts that I need some advice of getting
out of some of this is business some of
this is personal
mm-hmm so I'm total combined about three
hundred thousand dollars in debt and ya
get 225 as a house okay
okay yeah and then I got fifty three
thousand about 54,000 is two cars in
three credit cards how much of that land
Mars forty forty four thousand okay so
44 own cars and ten on credit cards yeah
close to ten on credit card see how kind
of gotcha
yes that's personal side so I closed the
business recently and look at I got
leftover some debts mm-hmm
which makes up the rest of the amount
that I chose what kind of doubt do you
have leftover from the business strictly
credit cards and how much is that
23400 okay that's not business debt it
occurred because of a business but it is
your personal name only
yeah becomes mine yeah that's thirty
three thousand dollars in credit card
debt
yeah combined yeah well it is kind of
how it's all in your name
yes in your mind is separated because of
what caused it but legally is absolutely
no separation yes okay so what do you
make here started negotiating with the
credit card companies you know are you
behind little yes over six months
well come on now just for the business
part of the debt which I understand is
still mine but just on the beginning
right okay twenty-three thousand you're
behind on ten you're current on yes okay
and why are you behind on the twenty
three you weren't able to pay it know
that what are you making here make
eighty thousand okay hmm
and so you have my wife and so if I was
that you can't afford I'm sorry you're
YX what my wife has some additional
income a fourteen thousand year
94,000 no and you've got almost $50,000
in card that you have cars that you
can't afford they need to go yeah that's
about $1,000 in payments right so
everything with you this yeah those need
to go away okay and then back to your
question on the credit card is what so
he I have two credit cards with it with
the bank days I owe about eighty three
hundred dollars and out of the twenty
three that I owe they said they'll be
willing to accept the payment fifty
percent if you get my four thousand
dollars they'll settle it yes after six
months yes okay
that's not bad usually they'll go less
than that but yeah but the bottom line
is you may need to make sure you get it
in writing and you settle them and you
pay for it yeah but but the truth is the
$23,000 in credit card debt is not your
problem your cars are your problem yeah
I see that too
yeah just to let you know some
additional stats I have about nine
thousand dollars left in cash in my
business account this is and I got six
thousand dollars in an emergency fund
personally and unfortunately last year
because of switching from closing my
business and switching to a new job I
did not pay any taxes to the IRS so I
will have a big tax bill coming what is
a big tax bill I don't haven't got my
taxes done yet for 2018 so I I don't
know what it is do that do that before
you said I'll do that before you settle
this credit card okay you need to get
the IRS out of your life first before
you do anything else how long will these
credit card companies going until they
decide to seal me years okay they're
going to call you every twenty minutes
have you already discovered that yeah
they're a pain in the butt but they're
pretty harmless it's just like a massive
mosquitos coming at you doesn't kill you
just aggravates the credit of you but
you know I want you to go back and clean
them up but you want to get the IRS out
of your life first it's much higher
penalties and interest and they have
unlimited power the credit cards are
quite the opposite they're gonna
discount deeply and it takes them is you
have to really really really get way
back there before they actually do come
after you and you're gonna address it
long long before then
what did you actually make in profit on
your business in eighteen I I couldn't
tell you these haven't got my taxes done
yet no would you like yes for me because
you closed it I'm guessing you didn't
have much profit
I stopped about two thousand seventeen
and I was actually doing really really
well I was making more money what I am
now but I had to close it for some
personal reasons so I saw Windows not
crazy did you not pay taxes for eighteen
or seventeen eighteen okay but you did
you make any money in eighteen I did not
genuine 2018 I took on a new job and I
was getting paid $800 a week and then I
had some additional funds that I paid
myself in the beginning of that year so
I think about total I took in is about
fifty thousand dollars 2018 okay so you
might have a ten or twelve thousand
dollar tax bill
yeah all right and you've got that money
in your accounts yeah yeah let me tell
you and the IRS is paying the IRS is
known as a freaking emergency yeah okay
so you have fifteen thousand dollars to
your name you no longer have a business
and legally you never had one anyway
because it's not stuff's all in your
name the cash is in your name the debt
is in your name so we got fifteen
thousand dollars to work against thirty
three thousand dollars in credit cards
and forty four thousand dollars in cars
and probably a fifteen thousand dollar
ten thousand dollar tax bill so go get
your taxes done today and figure out
what it is and then pay them I think
you're going to have the money to pay
them and then start working on settling
these credit cards as fast as you can
and working your way down from there and
let's get on a written budget and let's
get in control and let's start turning
this thing around you can do it you've
been through a hard time but you can do
it and if you need some more help you
call me anytime that's what we're here
for